Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, die 17. Ausgabe und heute dreht sich alles um die GPL, die GNU Public License und was das alles so für Folgewirkungen hat und am Mikrofon, wie gewohnt, Tim Pritlove und auch am Mikrofon, Harald Welte, der heute der Gast ist. So, und dann wollen wir auch gleich mal hier flix einsteigen in unseren Ablauf hier. Bevor wir hier in die Tiefe gehen, wollte ich erstmal ein bisschen Feedback einspielen. Haben wir nämlich bekommen, das finden wir auch total super. Und deswegen soll das hier auch zu Gehör kommen. Und dann fangen wir mal an mit Sebastian.
Ja, hallo, liebes Chaosradio-Team, hier ist Sebastian aus Essen. Ich wollte mich einfach für Chaosradio bedanken, besonders Chaosradio Express. Das gefällt mir extrem gut, weil es von der Länge her mit einer Stunde ziemlich genau meinen Arbeitsweg abdeckt und die ein oder andere Chaosradio-Sendung so meinen Arbeitsalltag doch erheblich verschönert hat.
Das freut uns natürlich, dass die Stunde hier genau passt. Eigentlich hatte ich immer versucht, das ein bisschen kürzer zu halten. Das wird uns wahrscheinlich auch heute wieder misslingen, denn das Thema ist zu interessant. Sehr umfangreich. Nicht wahr? Das haben wir eben schon gesehen, als wir mal ein paar Notizen gemacht haben. Da kann man lange drüber reden. Aber drei Stunden wie beim Chaosradio werden es nicht. Vielen Dank für das Feedback von Sebastian. Wir haben hier auch noch ein zweites. Da ist dann auch noch eine Frage mit drin, auf die wir dann auch gleich eingehen wollen. Fangen wir erstmal rein, was der Martin zu sagen hat.
Hier ist Martin aus Kreuzberg. Ich habe gestern und heute im Chaosradio Express Feed mit Begeisterung die alten CCC-Videos gesehen und war total geflasht. Ali Müller-Magun auf Jung habe ich eine Herzkasse gekriegt. Das Hartse war auch ein Video. Dieser graumelierte Herr, der am Anfang recht sympathisch wird, dann wird er immer schwieriger und im Abstand erfährt man dann, dass es Graben räumt. Großartige Videos, fand ich sehr super. Wollte mich auch noch für den Konkretgedanken, der war spannend wie er das Jahr super gemacht und wollte dann auch gleich noch fragen, es sollte eigentlich auf dem Konkret Johnny Heufler einen Vortrag halten, der ausgefahren ist und irgendwie, ich hab mal ein bisschen geschaut, hab auch bei ihm auf der Seite noch geschaut und würde irgendwie nie begründet, was da war. Ich weiß nicht, ob er sich dann entschlossen hat, Urlaub zu machen oder was, naja, vielleicht kann er natürlich, das wird so sein. Naja, dann bis im nächsten und weitesten.
Okay, das kam übrigens alles über das Chaosradio Feedback-Telefon, da werd ich auch nachher noch mal die Telefonnummer durchsagen und ihr könnt natürlich jederzeit anrufen. Zu deinen Hinweisen, also die Videos, auf die er sich bezieht, sind zwei Videos, die in den letzten Tagen hier auch aus dem Chaosradio Podcast herausgefallen sind. Das sind uralte Videos, mal von Barbara und Reena gemacht worden, Barbara Töns, Reena Tangens, auch schon seit Ewigkeiten beim CCC dabei und die Aufnahmen sind vom CoCon-Kongress. Kennste den noch?
Kennen wir nicht, ist mir nicht bekannt.
Das war die Veranstaltung, die 1990 noch zu DDR-Zeiten in Ostberlin stattfand, im Haus der jungen Talente, heute unter dem Namen Podeville bekannt. Da ist der Club relativ zügig, nachdem die Mauer gefallen war, rübermarschiert und hat einen Kongress gemacht. Und dort sind halt diese beiden Videos entstanden, der Stack und der Druckertreiber, die beide eigentlich die gleiche Idee verfolgen, nämlich man läuft einfach mal rum mit einer Kamera und fragt die Nerds, ob sie dir das nicht mal erklären können. Beim Druckertreiber kamen ja noch ein paar ganz brauchbare Antworten. Ich glaube Rob hat sich da am besten geschlagen, soweit ich mich da erinnere. Aber beim Stack ist es ja wirklich haarsträubend.
Zu den Videos fällt mir ein, da gibt es auch noch von den allerersten Chaos-Kongressen auch ein paar komische Videos.
Ja, es gibt noch so ein uraltes Video von 1987, das ist auch gerade aufgetaucht. Das werden wir hier die Tage auch mal in den Podcast werfen. Ja, Kongress wurde ja hier auch erwähnt im Feedback, schön, dass der gefallen hat. Der Vortrag von Johnny Häusler, genau, das war ein Vortrag von Johnny Häusler und Markus Beckendahl, der war angekündigt über Blogs. Da gab es dann einfach Terminprobleme und wir hatten sehr viel damit zu tun, den Kongress überhaupt erst mal auf die Reihe zu bekommen, deswegen haben wir da die Änderungsgründe auch nicht groß kommuniziert. Da gab es einfach Zeitprobleme und dann bin ich ja dann auch eingesprungen mit meinem Podcasting Vortrag. Mal schauen, ob wir da noch die Gelegenheit haben, das Blog-Thema nochmal aufzugreifen auf einem der kommenden Veranstaltungen. Aber da steckt dir jetzt keine besondere Sache oder keinen besonderen Grund dahinter, außer Zeitnot musste abgesagt werden. Ja, wo wir dann auch gerade beim Kongress sind, wir werden hier am Ende des Podcasts auch nochmal einen kleinen Ausblick machen, was an Veranstaltungen im deutschsprachigen Raum so demnächst ansteht. Aber eine andere Veranstaltung möchte ich hier vorher nochmal erwähnen, und zwar die von 2600 von den Hackern in New York, die Veranstaltung als HOPE. Und vor ein paar Tagen, also ich glaube vor zwei Wochen in der Radiosendung Off the Hook, die wöchentlich stattfindet, immer mittwochs, gibt es auch als Podcast, mittlerweile auch in besserer Qualität als bislang, wurde dann eben auch der 22C3 erwähnt. Und das werde ich mal kurz einspielen, dann kriegt ihr auch gleich nochmal einen Eindruck davon, wie diese Sendung ist. Ich habe die ja neulich schonmal angesprochen, aber leider kein Beispiel gespielt. Das mache ich jetzt mal. So, wir hören gleich Emmanuel Goldstein der Hauke.
Heute hatten wir das 109. Radio-Show von Chaosradio an einem FM-Station in Berlin, Deutschland. Das Show endete vor deinem Zeitpunkt. Grüße aus Berlin, hoffentlich sehen wir euch bei Hope oder 23C3, das 23. CCC-Kongress im nächsten Dezember in Berlin. Oliver aus congressradio.de. Wir hoffen, euch im Juli viele Deutsche bei unserer Konferenz in Juli zu sehen, z.B. Wir sind sicherlich in den Planungsstages der Konferenz, die am 21., Wir haben den Raum, wir haben einen tollen Raum im Mittelpunkt Manhattan. Du kannst nicht mehr einfach auf der Stelle sein, und es ist eine tolle Möglichkeit. Die Imagination ist dein Limit.
Ja, soweit im Manual. Er war ganz offensichtlich sehr angetan von dem letzten Kongress. Und wenn ihr noch nichts weiter vor habt, dann kann ich euch das auf jeden Fall auch empfehlen, euch da zu beteiligen. Ja, das bringt uns jetzt dann auch mal hier zu unserem eigentlichen Thema heute. GPL ist sicherlich vielen von euch bekannt, nicht unbedingt jedem, aber nicht unbedingt jedem ist so bekannt, welche Auswirkungen das Thema auch so gemeinnah hat. Du bist ja, Harald, du bist ja einer der Mitentwickler des Linus-Könnels, also du entwickelst einen Teil des Linus-Könnels mit. Das Netfilter-Projekt und bist von daher eben, was die GPL betrifft, an einer ganz interessanten Stelle, weil du ja sozusagen als Copyright-Owner oder als Urheber der einigen Software in dem Moment die Möglichkeit hast zu klagen, wenn jemand diesen Linus-Könnel verwendet. Das hast du eingesetzt in der letzten Zeit und da kam dann eben dieses GPL Violations-Projekt raus. Vielleicht erläuterst du einfach mal selber, was es damit genau auf sich hat.
Genau, vielleicht noch mal kurz vorher ausholen zur GPL und auch noch mal kurz auf deine Aussage eingehen, dass ich dann vorgehen kann, wenn jemand den Linux-Könnel verwendet. Natürlich ist es schön, wenn jemand den Linux-Könnel verwendet, das darf man nicht falsch verstehen, nur wenn jemand den Linux-Könnel in einer Art und Weise verwendet, wie er nicht mit der Lizenz, mit der GNU General Public License, der GPL im Einklang steht, dann kann ich eben vorgehen, weil ich einer der Urheberrechtsinhaber bin. Ja, die GPL noch mal kurz als Instrument dargestellt. Es geht also darum, dass man mit Hilfe des Urheberrechts, des Copyrights, die Freiheit von Software sicherstellt. Also dieser Copy-Left-Gedanke, den wir mittlerweile auch im Creative-Commons- Umfeld zum Beispiel kennen, ist vielleicht in den Podcast-Leuten geläufiger als Softwareentwicklung. Und die grundsätzliche Idee ist, wie gesagt, dass man das Urheberrecht zur Hilfe nimmt, um die Freiheit von, in dem Fall, Software aufrechtzuerhalten. Genau, man benutzt das Copyright, um sicherzustellen, dass immer dann, wenn jemand jetzt zum Beispiel eine GPL- lieziertes Software weitergibt, dass der Empfänger die Rechte bekommt, den Quellcode der Software lesen zu können, verändern zu können, veränderte Versionen der Programme weiter vertreiben zu können, diese veränderten Versionen ausführen zu können und so weiter. Es gibt eine ganze Reihe von Freiheiten, die durch die GPL gesichert werden und es gibt häufig Probleme im kommerziellen Einsatz, wenn Firmen nicht genügend Sorgfalt walten lassen oder sich zu wenig dafür interessieren oder es einfach nurmals drauf ankommen lassen. Dann kann es also hier zu viel Lizenzverstößen kommen. Das 0815 Beispiel hierfür ist einfach, ich bin eine Firma, wir nennen sie mal Evil Corp. Evil Corp baut ein Embedded-Gerät, das ist ein Router für DSL oder ähnliches.
Also Embedded sind diese kleinen Maschinen, die gar nicht nach Computer aussehen, aber natürlich auch für hier sinnvoll.
Richtig, aber es ist eigentlich auch egal. Ich habe das jetzt nur als Beispiel genommen, weil es sehr häufig vorkommt in diesem Bereich. Ich nehme da freie Software, zum Beispiel den Linux Kernel, zum Beispiel die GNU C-Library oder viele GPL- oder LGPL-licensierte Software und verdreibe diesen Router dann. Es geht also gar nicht mal ums Verkaufen, sondern es geht um den Vertrieb. Auch wenn ich die verschenken würde, könnte ich immer noch einen GPL-Verstoß begehen, wenn ich nämlich nicht den Quellcode mitliefere oder aber ein schriftliches Angebot mitliefere, dass ich den Quellcode auf Anfrage bereitstelle und eben auch darauf hinweise, dass dieses Gerät GPL-licensierte Software enthält, damit der Abnehmer überhaupt in die Lage versetzt wird, zu wissen, dass er hier mehr Freiheiten hat, als er das normalerweise gewohnt ist, wenn er ein Produkt erwirbt. Na ja, so kann man das nicht sagen. Also man darf nicht denken, dass die Masse der Geräte oder der Software, die mit Hilfe von freier Software in den Markt gebracht wird, dass die GPL-Verstöße hätten. Aber es ist halt nicht, dass so, also trotzdem sind sehr viele Produkte, die mit GPL-Verstößen verhaftet sind, kommen in den Umlauf, wenn nur mal um so eine grobe. Ich meine, ich bekomme ja auch nur einen Bruchteil davon mit. Weltweit kommen ständig, gerade im Embedded-Bereich, unglaublich viele Produkte auf den Markt, von denen auch über den Daumen gepeilt würde ich sagen, so 30 bis 40 Prozent mittlerweile eben Linux einsetzen zum Beispiel.
30 bis 40 Prozent meinst du denn? Also so Router, WLAN-Router, sowas, diese Kategorie.
Set-top-Boxen sieht man es auch verstärkt.
Telefonanlagen auch schon?
Telefonanlagen, na ja, wenn es im Voice-over-IP-Bereich reingeht, ist es auch sehr häufig der Fall. Es sind so kombinierte Geräte, wo ich dann sowohl ISDN, als auch Voice-over-IP zum Beispiel damit machen kann. Wo sehen wir es noch? Wir sehen es bei MP3-Playern, bei Personal Media-Playern, wir sehen es bei Navigationssystemen, für das Auto.
Und demnächst wohl auch Telefonen, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Richtig, Telefone auch. Auch jetzt schon nicht nur demnächst, aber demnächst noch verstärkt. Also Telefone, in dem Fall Handys, Mobiltelefone, aber eben auch Voice-over-IP-Telefone, das auch weit verbreitet wird. Also es gibt einen unglaublichen Markt von Geräten, denen Linux zum Einsatz kommt. Oder auch andere Fire-Software, das hat ja nichts Spezifisches.
Die Linux hat eigentlich den Embedded-Markt in der Tasche, oder?
Im Moment sieht es für weite Bereiche so aus.
Ich sehe eigentlich kaum Alternativen. Ich meine, wenn, dann gibt es vielleicht noch so QNX oder solche Betriebssysteme.
WX wirkt es ja stark noch.
Ja, die so ganz kleine Echtzeitsegmente aber im Prinzip nur abdecken. Und alles, was so General Purpose ist, sehe ich eigentlich nur noch Linux. Also früher war da ja DOS ganz stark, aber davon ist ja wenig übrig geblieben.
Na ja, ist es halt so, dass die Funktionen, die die Geräte implementieren, wird immer komplexer, die CPU-Power der Geräte wird immer größer. Und damit ist sozusagen das, was ich eigentlich als General Purpose-Betriebssystem habe, wie jetzt Linux oder auch BSD-Betriebssysteme, die werden auf einmal für Embedded-Produkte interessant. Es ist halt viel einfacher, High-Level-Software zu entwickeln, wenn ich ein richtiges, anständiges, normales Betriebssystem darunter liegen habe und nicht irgendeinen komischen Echtzeitkönnel, der eigenartige Schnittstellen hat und eben ganz anders aussieht wie Software-Entwicklungen auf dem PC zum Beispiel. Aber gut, um die Kurve wieder Richtung GPL zu kriegen, ist es sicherlich so, dass viele Firmen und Produkte sich da korrekt verhalten und sich auch sehr bemühen. Das ist ja gar nicht die Frage, nur gibt es eben auch eine ganze Reihe von Produkten, wo es ein Problem ist. Ich habe mittlerweile einen Request-Tracker in diesem GPL Violations Project, das ich gleich noch beschreiben werde. Im Moment habe ich da so um den Daumen 100 offene Tickets an Lizenzverstößen. Das ist schon einiges.
Es gibt ja bei vielen Firmen durchaus Widerstände. Überhaupt GPL, also die Lizenz, als solche gegen die Lizenz gibt es Widerstände. Siehst du das teilweise auch gerechtfertigt an? Meist ist die Meinung, dass die GPL nicht für alle Fälle geeignet ist oder dass da eigentlich nur ein bisschen Paranoia und Angst bestätigend begründet ist?
Das ist schwierig. Es ist halt die Frage, was für Dinge setze ich als gegeben voraus. Ich denke nicht, dass die GPL grundsätzlich ein Problem darstellt für eigentlich egal welchen Bereich. Es ist halt nur so, dass viele Firmen sich aus ihrer Businesskultur heraus schwer tun, diese Umstellung hinzubekommen oder diese andere Welt wahrzunehmen in ihrer Ganzheit. Das ist so, wenn ich mich entscheide, GPL-lizenzierte Software mit in einem Produkt einzusetzen, dann hat es doch einige Folgen. Angenommen, wenn ich mich im Betriebssystem-Bereich bewege, wo wir auch schon waren, im Vated-Betriebssystem, und wenn ich da irgendeinen Profil, der das Betriebssystem lizenziert, dann ist es relativ klar, ich muss da für jede Kopie irgendeine Royalty, irgendeine Gebühr abdrücken und damit hat sich das Ganze dann für mich erledigt. Dann kann ich vom einem zum anderen gehen und das ist dann überall im Prinzip das Gleiche. Die Gebühren unterscheiden sich und die Funktionen des Betriebssystems unterscheiden sich. Gehe ich in Richtung GPL-lizenzierter Software, dann habe ich überhaupt keine Frage in Richtung Geld, weil die Software ist kostenlos, zum Download verfügbar. Aber was ich dann eben habe, sind andere Pflichten, die da eben nach sich gezogen werden, wie zum Beispiel, dass ich eben den Quellcode herausgeben muss, dass ich meine Abnehmer in die Lage versetzen muss, veränderte Versionen dieser Software auch ausführen zu können und solche Dinge. Das ist halt was, was rein aus dem traditionellen Business denken, dieser Branche ungewohnt für sie ist und deswegen fällt das denen halt schwer. Und wer jetzt sagt, ich möchte mich gar nicht erst damit beschäftigen mit diesen ganzen Dingen, der bleibt halt dann eben bei anderer Software. Das ist ja eben so eingestellt.
Ja, ich denke, wir sollten vielleicht nachher dann auch noch mal so einen kleinen Leitfaden zusammenstellen, was man denn so zu bedenken hat, wenn man jetzt selber als Firma darüber nachdenkt, so etwas in einem eigenen Produkt einzusetzen. Aber vielleicht gehen wir vorher noch mal auf dieses GPL Violations-Projekt zurück. Steht das eigentlich im Wesentlichen nur aus dir oder?
Lange Zeit, mittlerweile gibt es Unterstützung. Also die Grundidee oder der Gedanke hinter dem GPL Violations-Org-Projekt ist eben, bekannte Verletzungen der GNU General Public License überhaupt erst mal zu dokumentieren, zu sammeln und dann sofern möglich, außergerichtlich und im Zweifelsfall auch gerichtlich, eben die Lizenz durchzusetzen. Das geht natürlich nur, wie du auch eingangs schon erwähnt hast, wenn jemand Rechte hält an der entsprechenden Software. Das heißt im Zweifelsfall, wenn es Software ist, wo ich Rechte habe, dann ist es natürlich günstig, dann kann ich selber einfach nur mit mir selber sozusagen die Entscheidung fällen. Wenn es Software von anderen Leuten ist, dann kann man ja diese entsprechenden Autoren ansprechen, kann sie fragen, ob sie interessiert wären, ob sie schon wissen, dass da überhaupt die Rechte der Software verletzt werden und dann entsprechende Optionen besprechen. Aber es geht eben um das Sammeln von Informationen und um das Durchsetzen der Lizenz. Es ist eine Aufgabe der Free Software Foundation, das ist ja die Erfindung dieser GNU General Public License, die die Richard Stolman mal gegründet hat. Richtig, ja. Die macht ja auch die Fair Enforcement, das darf man jetzt nicht so falsch verstehen, als ob nur dieses Projekt, das ich gegründet habe, Lizenzdurchsetzung macht. Die Free Software Foundation macht das seit wahrscheinlich 20 Jahren, da habe ich jetzt keine Zahlen dazu, wann der erste Fall aufgetreten ist, aber... Der Unterschied ist, dass die Free Software Foundation das eben nicht publik mag, das heißt, die spricht so mit den betreffenden Firmen, da wird nie was öffentlich gemacht darüber, es ist nicht bekannt, dass überhaupt Enforcement passiert. Also mir ist das auch erst sehr spät bekannt geworden, als ich mal zufällig irgendwo einen Bericht gelesen habe, wo sie gesagt haben, dieses Jahr haben wir wieder 20 oder 30 Fälle oder irgendwas gehabt, stand irgendwo so im Rechenschaftsbericht nach einem Jahr oder so im des Vorstands, stand das irgendwo in einem Absatz erwähnt, aber es wird eben nicht publik gemacht und man versucht sich hier möglichst freundlich mit den Firmen irgendwie auseinanderzusetzen und er zieht auch eigentlich rechtliche Schritte, meiner Auffassung nach nur eher theoretischen Erwägungen, weniger praktisch.
Warum machen die das so im stillen und geheimen? Man möchte doch eigentlich meinen, dass man da gleich richtig auf die Kacke hauen sollte in dem Moment.
Ja, das ist ein bisschen ein kultureller Unterschied. Also man darf das auch nicht als Konkurrenzmiss verstehen. Ich respektiere die FSL von was sie tut und umgekehrt auch. Wir reden auch viel miteinander. Ich habe Kontakt zu Ivan Moglen. Das ist so der Rechtsberater im Legal Council, der auch der Jurist, der hinter der GPL steht, letztendlich. Und die amerikanische Businesskultur und auch Rechtskultur ist ein bisschen anders als das bei uns hier der Fall ist. Und da gibt es auch andere Bestimmungen, was zum Beispiel die Veröffentlichung von irgendwelchen Rechtsstreitigkeiten angeht. Also wenn ich da irgendwas veröffentliche, dann hat das gleich irgendwelche rechtlichen Folgen für mich. Und die sind da also kulturell einfach anders geprägt. Hier ist das in Deutschland einfach anders. Also der Zweck oder der Sinn, warum ich so eine andere Strategie verfolge, ist eben, dass meiner Meinung nach gerade die Öffentlichkeit dazu helfen müsste, weitere neue Fälle zu verhindern. Einfach das Bewusstsein in den Management-Etagen der Firmen irgendwie zu erzeugen, dass man hier ein paar Regeln beachten muss, ist ja wirklich nicht viel. Und sozusagen präventiv da auch tätig zu werden durch diese Öffentlichkeitsarbeit.
Wodurch ist denn das alles losgetreten worden? Also wann fing denn das an, das Projekt?
Das war im Sommer 2003, als der Linksys-Fall zum ersten Mal publik wurde. Da ging es also um diesen berühmten Linksys-WRT-54G. Da ist also bekannt geworden, dass die Firma Linksys, damals glaube ich noch keine Tochter der Cisco-Systems, ein Produkt auf den Markt gebracht hat, eben einen WLAN-Router, also ein schnurloser Netzwerk-Router, der Linux basiert ist und dort die Lizenz missachtet hat. Und dann hat sich eine Allianz gegründet unter der Leitung der Free Software Foundation, die versucht hat, hier die Rechte einzufordern und das Ganze hat sich irgendwie vier Monate oder so hingezogen und nach vier Monaten haben sie dann das erste Mal irgendwie so ein Häppchen-Quel-Code ausgespuckt, das war nicht vollständig und die Pflichten waren immer noch nicht umgesetzt und so weiter und so weiter. Währenddessen läuft der Vertrieb und der Verkauf weiter, also das fanden halt einige Leute nicht die richtige Herangehensweise.
So eine Verzögerungstaktik sozusagen.
Genau, eine Verzögerungstaktik, weil im Grunde ist es ja so, wenn man das rechtlich betrachtet, hat der Urheber, der den Software lizenziert, jetzt unter der GPL zum Beispiel, hat der einen Unterlassungsanspruch gegen jeden, der die eben gegen diese Lizenz vertreibt, die Software. Das heißt, wenn jetzt Evil Corp, um wieder auf das Beispiel zurückzugreift, wenn die jetzt hier über irgendwie den, was weiß ich, den Einzelhandel um die Ecke ein Produkt vertreiben, in dem lizenzmäßig GPL lizenzierte Software ist, dann habe ich sowohl gegen den Einzelhandel als auch gegen den Großhändler als auch gegen die Evil Corp letztendlich und so weiter habe ich als einer der Urever einen Unterlassungsanspruch. Das heißt, ich kann mit sofortiger Wirkung fordern, dass die das korrigieren und dass die keine Gidreite mehr vertreiben, die lizenzwidrig sind. Und wenn so eine Firma sich jetzt durch verzögerungsdachtig Zeit erkauft, dann können die ihre kompletten Lagerbestände und was die so alles haben noch abverkaufen, ohne dass sie eben dort den Quellcode beilegen oder die Lizenz erwähnen oder was auch immer. Also da ist schon viel Taktiererei auch dabei. Und wie gesagt, der linkseste Fall war dann der Auslöser, dass einige...
Du hast gesagt, da hätte sich eine Allianz gebildet, dagegen vorzugehen. Wer war Teil dieser Allianz?
Na, soviel ich weiß. Also die Free Software Foundation, die ja eben auch Rechte gehalten hat. Da waren eigentlich Bibliotheken drin, die die FSF hält. Dann ein paar Kernentwickler, ich eben auch für das Netfilter-Projekt. Da war auch dabei, meines Wissens, der Busy Box Autor, der Eric Andersen. Also Busy Boxes wird immer als das...
Diese Unix-Umgebung für Embedded-Geräte.
Genau.
Schön platzsparend.
Genau. Das ist ein Schweizer Messer, wird es immer bezeichnet, der Embedded-Geräte. Und ich kann jetzt gar nicht sagen, wer da noch so dabei war, aber es sind halt eine ganze Reihe von unterschiedlichen Leuten, die alle Rechte an Software gehalten haben in dem Produkt.
Man merkt aber auch schon, dass das Thema in der Entwicklergemeinde einfach präsent ist. Das läuft nicht so nebenbei.
Bei den meisten Leuten ja. Es ist ja so, wenn man Software schreibt, frei Software, kann man sich ja entscheiden, lizenziere ich die unter einer Copy-Left-Lizenz wie der GPL oder stelle ich es unter eine freier Lizenz, also freier in Anführungszeichen, wie die BSD-Lizenz. Die BSD-Lizenzen, die ermöglichen es ja, kommerzielle oder auch nicht kommerzielle Produkte abzuleiten von dem ursprünglichen Werk und diese eben ohne Quellcode weiter zu vertreiben. Und wenn ich jetzt als Entwickler mich aktiv entscheide und sage, nein, ich möchte unter der GPL lizenzieren, weil ich halt dieses Modell der Freiheit und der Sicherung der Rechte eben, dass jeder in die Lage wird, zu lernen und das zu verändern und so weiter, wenn ich daran glaube und das halt so eine Motivation mit ist, dann mache ich das ja eben aus dem wichtigen Grund, weil ich daran glaube und dann bewegt mich das schon auch, wenn da jemand dagegen verstößt. Sicher gibt es jetzt nicht viele, die selber tatsächlich rechtliche Schritte einleiten würden. Ich meine, es sind alles Software-Entwickler, die meisten machen es in ihrer Freizeit, alles Techniker und die wenigsten haben Lust, irgendwie mit Anwälten zu reden oder irgendwie dann vielleicht noch gar vor Gericht zu gehen oder so. Und das war dann eben bei mir auch so der Fall, als dann die nächsten Fälle hochkamen, nach diesem ersten Linkses Fall kamen dann eine Reihe weiterer Fälle mit ähnlichen Produkten auch. Und da habe ich dann hier in Deutschland versucht, irgendwie gute anwältliche Beratung zu finden. Es gibt in Deutschland tatsächlich ein Institut für Rechtsfragen der freien und Open Source Software, das sogenannte IFROS. Ja, und da habe ich dann konfidente Ansprechpartner gesetzt.
Wo sitzen die?
Das ist eher so ein, also sie sitzen in München, aber es ist eher so virtuell. Es sind halt irgendwie ein paar Anwälte aus dem deutschsprachigen Raum, es ist auch eine österreichische Anwältin dabei, die sich halt seit langem rechtswissenschaftlich mit diesen Fragen und freier Software und die Lizenzen beschäftigt. IFROS, genau, von Borg. Und da habe ich dann eben, wie gesagt, eine gute Beratung gefunden und hatte dann überlegt, ob ich das Risiko eingehen will, da mal die Rechte auch juristisch durchzusetzen. Und das hat dann gut funktioniert beim ersten Mal. Und dann habe ich es halt wieder gemacht und wieder und wieder. Und jetzt haben wir, glaube ich, irgendwie so um die 60, 70 Fälle hinter uns.
Ich mir richtig erinnere, der Hebe ging aber letzten Endes gar nicht so richtig gegen Linkses, sondern gegen jemanden, der diese Hardware vertrieben hat, gegen Sidecom.
Na, das war jetzt ein anderes Produkt, ein anderes Produkt. Also die Fälle haben mit nichts zu tun, also weder von der Hardware her noch von der Software noch sonst nichts getrennt.
Der Sidecom-Fall war insofern besonders, dass es da erstmal rechtlichen Widerstand gab, also seitens der Firma.
Ja, also der Sidecom-Fall war nicht der erste Fall, wo GPL Violations aktiv geworden ist. In den vorhergehenden Fällen hat man halt über einen Anwalt die Firmen angeschrieben und dann haben die Firmen gesagt, oh ja, da haben wir einen Fehler gemacht, tut uns leid, wir unterschreiben, dass wir es nicht mehr tun, also so eine Unterlassungserklärung abgeben und damit war die Sache dann meistens gegessen. Bei Sidecom hingegen, die haben sich also geweigert, eine Unterlassungserklärung abzugeben und haben gesagt, nee, wir machen nichts Falsches oder das ist alles in Ordnung oder wie auch immer und haben sich dagegen eben verwehrt und dann sind wir vor Gericht gegangen, haben so eine 1-2-Wahl-Verfügung beantragt und das heißt dann letztendlich, dass das Gericht Sidecom vorschreibt, dass die Geräte nicht mehr vertrieben werden dürfen, solange sie nicht mit der GPL in Eingang sind und Sidecom hat dann dagegen Widerspruch eingelegt, also quasi wie eine Revision in sich Widerspruch bei diesen 1-2-Wahl-Verfügungen. Da gab es dann eine mündliche Verhandlung beim Landgericht München und auch dort ist dann der Widerspruch zurückgewiesen worden, das heißt also das Gericht hat die 1-2-Wahl-Verfügung aufrechterhalten und wir haben gewonnen damit.
Wie schnell, also was für Zeiträumen reden wir da? Also ihr habt erstmal die angeschrieben und dann haben sie erstmal nicht reagiert oder dann haben sie gleich gesagt nö oder?
Also es ist so, dass man um eine 1-2-Wahl-Verfügung beantragen zu können in Deutschland, muss man die Wichtigkeit oder die Dringlichkeit nachweisen können und das hängt ein bisschen vom Gericht ab, weil in dem zuständigen Landgericht München ist es so, dass die 30 Tage als Frist setzen. Das heißt, wenn ich von einem Rechtsverstoß als rechte Inhaber erfahre, dann habe ich 30 Tage lang Zeit eine 1-2-Wahl-Verfügung zu beantragen. Wenn ich das innerhalb der Zeit nicht tue, dann ist mir das nicht dringend genug und dann kann ich auch den Wegen des normalen zivilrechtlichen Prozesses gehen, das dauert dann ein, zwei Jahre oder so. Also für die Softwarebranche und für die IT-Branche im Zeitraum, da sind die Geräte gar nicht mehr am Markt in der Regel. Also kein gangbarer Weg. Das heißt, man hat diese vier Wochen Zeit zu verhandeln, außergerichtlich oder zu einer Einigung zu kommen und wenn man das nicht tut, dann muss man sich spätestens nach vier Wochen die Frage stellen, will ich jetzt eine 1-2-Wahl-Verfügung beantragen oder nicht.
Und als die Verfügung dann draußen war, dann haben die sozusagen sofort Widerspruch eingelegt und hat das dann die 1-2-Wahl-Verfügung aufgehoben?
Nein. Also die 1-2-Wahl-Verfügung bleibt erst mal. Man kann, also es gibt auch Fälle, wohl so rein juristisch, wo jemand Widerspruch einreicht und dann nach Aktenlage schon entschieden wird, aha, der Widerspruch ist berechtigt, da war irgendwas komplett falsch, die wird aufgelöst, die 1-2-Wahl-Verfügung. Aber bei uns war das ja alles wasserdicht und dann hat das Gericht einen mündlichen Termin anberaumt. Das ist dann vielleicht noch mal so ein Monat nach der 1-2-Wahl-Verfügung gewesen, so vom zeitlichen Abstand her oder vielleicht ein bisschen mehr. Und die ist aber aktiv, also die ist aktiv, diese 1-2-Wahl-Verfügung bis dahin. Es ist halt nur so, dass gesetztenfalls, die dürfen ja keine Geräte mehr verkaufen, zumindest solange sie nach wie vor nicht mit der GPL in Einklang haben. Und wenn dann in einem Monat später oder zwei, wenn diese mündliche Verhandlung ist im Widerspruch, wenn dann entschieden wird, ach nee, die war ja von vornherein nicht rechtens diese 1-2-Wahl-Verfügung, dann bin ich wieder im Umkehrschluss haftbar für die Geschäftsausfälle von der Firma, was natürlich je nach Größe der Firma und Stückzahlen und Preis der Produkte und so schon beträchtige Summen.
Aber du warst ja da glaube ich relativ sicher, dass du da, oder?
Ja, naja, es ist schon...
Schon ein doofes Gefühl, wenn man mit so was morgens aufwacht.
Es ist nicht ganz ohne, das ist richtig. Allerdings, Sidecom war von vielen Seiten her günstig. Also die haben einfach in Deutschland auch nicht so wahnsinnig viele Geräte verkauft, das war klar. Also es gab wenige Händler, die die nur vertrieben haben. Das heißt, durch diesen Fall hätte man schon sagen können, das Risiko ist etwa beschränkt. Also alleine das Risiko an Rechtskosten, also gegenrische Anwälte, eigener Anwalt, Gericht usw. wären knapp 10.000 Euro gewesen. Und wenn jetzt da noch so Geschäftsausfälle oder irgendwas dazugekommen wäre, das wäre natürlich schon nochmal eine Ecke größer, aber trotzdem noch ein halbwegs überschaubarer Bereich. Mich hat's gereizt und ich dachte mir, wir können uns das als entwicklerfreie Software nicht länger bieten lassen, wenn wir da nur tatenlos zusehen und uns da nicht dagegen wehren, dann nimmt das überhand und dann ist die ganze GPL irgendwie sinnlos.
Das Widerspruchsverfahren wurde dann abgelehnt von dem Gericht?
Na, es gab das Widerspruchsverfahren, aber der Widerspruch selber ist halt zurückgewiesen worden.
Ist das jetzt so eine Sache von einer Stunde gewesen oder haben die sich dann noch mal richtig lange zurückgezogen und wirklich nachgedacht, worum es ging? Das heißt, für die war das relativ offensichtlich, dass dieser Lizenzverstoß auch vorlag. Also, die haben das nicht groß in Zweifel gezogen?
Nein, haben sie nicht. Was für mich außerordentlich erstaunlich war, ist, dass sie nicht mal eine beglaubigte deutsche Übersetzung der GPL genommen haben, sondern sie haben den englischen Originaltext daran gezogen. Also, für ein deutsches Gesicht war das für mich irgendwie unglaublich.
Gibt es denn überhaupt eine offizielle deutsche Übersetzung der GPL?
Nein, es gibt überhaupt keine offiziellen Übersetzungen. In keine Sprache meines Wissens. Es gibt halt das englische Original und alle Übersetzungen, die im Netz so kursieren, sind inoffizielle Übersetzungen. Und im Zweifelsfall würde man immer auf den englischen Wortlaut zurückgreifen, wenn es um Auslegungsfragen geht. Aber in der Regel ist es eben schon so vor deutschen Gerichten, dass die entsprechenden Schriftsetze in deutscher Sprache beigebracht werden müssen. Das heißt, man braucht eben dann einen vereidigten Übersetzer, der das versucht, zu übersetzen, so genau wie es geht. Aber das war jetzt gar nicht notwendig.
Aber die GPL bezieht sich doch im Wesentlichen auf das US-amerikanische Rechtssystem in ihrer Formulierung, oder?
Das ist richtig. Das ist auch etwas, was ich so erstaunlich finde an der GPL. Sie wurde ja ursprünglich geschrieben im amerikanischen Copyright-System für die Leute, die das nicht wissen. Es gibt also in der Welt im Wesentlichen zwei große Unterschiede zwischen den Urheberrechtssystemen. Das eine ist das Copyright, was in den USA und in Großbritannien weit verbreitet ist, und auch in Australien, also überall wo die Engländer mal kolonialisiert haben. Und im kontinentale europäischen Bereich, vor allem Frankreich und Deutschland, da gibt es das sogenannte droit d'auteur, also das Recht des Autors. Deswegen heißt das bei uns ja auch nicht Copyrecht oder so, sondern es heißt Urheberrecht, weil es eben um den Urheber und seine Rechte geht. Das hat ganz unterschiedliche Auswirkungen, da will ich jetzt aber nicht so sehr abschweifen, aber es ist erstaunlich, dass die GPL, obwohl sie eben für dieses völlig andere Rechtssystem geschrieben wurde, trotzdem in Ländern wie Deutschland, die aus dieser anderen Tradition heraus stammen, nahezu uneingeschränkt anwendbar ist.
Zumal es ja auch bis dahin auch in anderen Ländern gar keine Präzedenzfälle gab, oder?
Präzedenzfälle im juristischen Sinne?
Also, dass jetzt vor Gerichten in irgendeiner Form festgestellt wurde, dass diese GPL auch wirklich gültig ist und dass es nicht nur ein Stück Papier ist, sondern dass man damit auch was anfangen kann?
Nein, das gab es nicht. Es gab sehr wohl Rechtsstreite um die GPL schon. Es gab da einen Fall zu Mayes Quell in den USA mal. Die sind aber nie rechtskräftig. Also, da gab es einen Rechtsstreit, der ist dann außergerichtlich geeinigt worden und damit gibt es keinen Präzedenzfall, weil kein Richter entschieden hat.
Aber bei 50 Fällen, sagst du, 50 pro Jahr, was die FSF so berichtet hat in ihrem Bericht, 30, wundert mich. Ist das immer alles so still und heimlich dann so gelaufen?
Ja, das ist schon erstaunlich. Zumal man ja eigentlich in den USA immer sehr schnell ist irgendwie mit Klagen und Riesensummen und allem Möglichen. Ich finde es auch erstaunlich. Aber es ist halt schon auch so, dass jetzt eine Firma sozusagen gegen die Free Software Foundation vorzugehen in der Rechtsstreitigkeit um die GPL. Ich meine, egal wie viel oder wenig die von Freier Software oder der GPL wissen, spätestens die Anwälte, die qualifizierten, die sie dann engagieren, die wissen dann schon, dass es hier also um eine ganz grundsätzliche Entscheidung geht und einen äußerst wichtigen Fall. Und es ist halt auch nicht unbedingt die Sache jeder Firma, dann da so Grundsatzentscheidungen sozusagen vom Zaun brechen zu wollen, weil man weiß, dass man das durch alle Instanzen durchtreiben müsste, wahrscheinlich, weil die andere Partei ja dann auch nicht nachgibt und so. Das ist schon nicht unbedingt eine Sache, die es jeder so einfach mal locker eben aus dem Ärmel schüttelt, also auch von den Firmen.
Und siehst du da jetzt so einen Trend hin zur Akzeptanz der GPL oder ist das nach wie vor ein offenes Spiel?
Ich denke, es ist ein bisschen marktbereichsspezifisch. Also bei diesen Wireless-Geräten, WLAN-Router, DSL-Router und so, da muss ich feststellen, dass eine größere Zahl, eine zunehmende Zahl der neuen Geräte, die auf den Markt kommen, jetzt GPL compliant sind, wenn sie auf den Markt kommen. Das ist also sehr erfreulich. Dafür gibt es ständig neue Bereiche, wo die Firmen einfach, die Firmen, die da involviert sind, sowohl Software-Entwicklung als auch dann meistens die Fertigung und das Kopieren usw. passiert ja meistens in Taiwan, Korea und dergleichen. Also alle beteiligten Parteien einfach noch nicht so damit vertraut sind mit der Materie und dann sieht man eben in diesen anderen Märkten die gleichen Probleme auch wieder. Jetzt in den letzten, sagen wir ein, zwei Monaten, habe ich persönlich wieder von dem, was ich mitbekomme, einen ganz deutlichen Anstieg an GPL-Verletzungen und Anfällen gesehen. Das ist aber ja auch nicht repräsentativ, das ist halt nur das, was ich mitbekomme.
Ja, da gibt es ja jetzt auch einen brandaktuellen Fall, der vor ein paar Tagen in die Nachrichten gekommen ist. Da geht es um die österreichische Gesundheitskarte. Was hat es da jetzt genau mit auf sich? Was ist da jetzt konkret von der GPL betroffen?
Ja, es gibt in Österreich den Dachverband der Sozialversicherungsträger, das ist so ein Dachverband der gesetzlichen Krankenkassen und Ähnlichem. Die haben ja unter Gesellschaft ausgegründet die sogenannte SVC-BUE-GMWH, Sozialversicherungsschipkartenbetriebs- und Errichtungs-GMWH. Das passt kaum mehr in so ein Brieffenster. Also wenn man die anschreiben will, dass dieses Fenster von dem Dean Langumschlag ist fast voll. Scherz beiseite, auf jeden Fall, diese Firma hat den Auftrag, dieses Gesundheitskarten-Netzwerk und das System zu errichten. Das heißt, da hat ja jeder Bürger, ähnlich wie das uns auch noch bevorsteht, eine Gesundheitskarte bekommen und die Arztpraxen wurden landesweit alle mit entsprechenden Lesegeräten und Computern und so weiter ausgestattet.
Die Umstellung ist schon abgeschlossen?
Nein, es gibt Ärzte, die sich vehement wehren dagegen. Das ist in Österreich eine riesige Debatte, diese Gesundheitskarte. Also ganz völlig unabhängig von GPL und irgendwelchen Lizenzfragen, das ist nur eine der vielen Facetten. Und es gibt also Ärzte, die vehement das einfach nicht wollen und die das polkotieren und die das nicht installieren lassen, weiß ich, wie das dann aussieht oder was die Möglichkeiten haben, keine Ahnung. Ich habe mich da nicht damit beschäftigt im Detail. Was die GPL anbetrifft, ist eben so, dass in jede Arztpraxis, Ordination, wie das ja in Österreich so schön heißt, überhaupt, wer dachte, dass Juristen Deutsch, also das in Deutschland gesprochen und geschrieben wird, wirklich ist, dann muss ich mal österreichisches Juristen Deutsch antun. Das ist nochmal eine Kategorie interessanter. Aber gut. Jedenfalls, jede Arztordination bekommt da ein solches GINA, das ist der Gesundheitsinformationsnetzwerkadapter, das ist auch wieder ein schönes Wort, was technisch gesehen eben ein Gerät ist, das zum einen an einen speziellen DSL-Anschluss angeschlossen wird. Der DSL-Anschluss ist nicht verbunden mit dem Internet, sondern mit dem GIN, mit dem Gesundheitsinformationsnetz, und auf der anderen Seite ist eben das Praxisnetz, in dem auch die Gesundheitskartenlesegeräte hängen. Das ist ein Gateway und da läuft allerhand Software drauf und wenn man mal ein bisschen unter die Haube schaut, dann ist das eine MIPS-Box mit Debian GNU Linux drunter. Und da wurde eben niemand, also weder der Ärzteverband noch die einzelnen Ärzte, noch sonst irgendjemand, der damit zu tun hat, darüber aufgeklärt, dass das freie Software ist, dass man bestimmte Rechte hat an der Software, dass man in Quellcode kommen kann usw. Und dann habe ich erstmal den Nachweis, man muss ja mal, bevor man da irgendwie aktiv wird, erstmal richtig einen Nachweis fahren. Was wir da konkret gemacht haben, ist, dass wir einen Sniffer zwischen dieser Maschine und das Gesundheitsinformationsnetz gehängt haben, der alles mitprotokolliert und dann waren da die Updates über HTTP, also wer Debian kennt, der weiß, da waren Updates über Webverbindungen heruntergeladen.
Automatische Software-Aktualisierung?
Genau, und das sozusagen mitgeschnitten und dann aufgrund dessen nachgewiesen hier, da findet Vertrieb von GPL-sensierter Software statt.
Ich dachte schon, jetzt kommen hier so abgefahrene Probings mit Nmap oder so.
Das hat ja alles keine Beweiskraft oder so. Genau, als ersten Hinweis kann man das akzeptieren.
Aber so eine Box selber in der Hand gehabt hast du jetzt nicht und auch nicht firmware ausgelesen oder so?
Nein, nein.
Warum nicht?
Weil ich in Berlin sitze und nicht in Österreich. Das ist eigentlich der wesentliche Grund. Ich hatte dann jemanden, der als vereidigter Sachverständiger in Österreich anerkannt ist, der hat diese Sniffen in Österreich gemacht. Das heißt, der hätte im Zweifelsfall vor Gericht, wenn es denn dort hingegangen wäre, bezeugen können, dass das irgendwie hier genau das ist, was diese Kiste mit dem Netz gesprochen hat und so weiter. Aber gut, dann ist man eben auf diese SVC-BUE-GMWH zugegangen und hat sie abgemahnt. Über die Details kann ich jetzt nicht sprechen in dem speziellen Fall. Ich kann nur sagen, es gab eine Einigung und der Quellcode ist verfügbar. Die Ärzteverbände wurden über die GPL aufgeklärt und informiert. Dann wurde ein Schreiben versandt. Jetzt ist das also weitestgehend aus der Welt.
Dann nehme ich doch mal an, dass die Projektpartner auch alle wieder sehr überrascht waren. Wahrscheinlich haben die Ärzte davon noch von GPL noch nie was gehört.
Interessant ist, dass mich hinten herum die Entwickler dieser Produkte kontaktiert haben, die diese Anpassung des Debian GNU-Linux-Firms auf diese Hardware gemacht haben. Oder einer zumindest von Leuten, die da involviert sind. Der kann jetzt natürlich auch keinen Namen nennen. Die meinten, sie hätten über Monate hinweg ihr Management die ganze Zeit darauf hingewiesen, aber die wollten einfach nicht hinhören. Ich kenne diese Leute nicht, ich kann nicht authentisieren, dass es tatsächlich diese Entwickler sind, aber es gibt zumindest Leute, die sich bei mir gemeldet haben.
Das Nafo-Prinzip kann man wieder voll zur Anwendung.
Das ist auch etwas, was ich jetzt so rein im Überblick über all die Fälle, die ich jetzt so hatte, sehe, ist, dass häufig die Entwickler mehr Ahnung von dem rechtlichen Hintergrund zur GPL-sitzierter Software haben, als das ihr Management hat und dass das dann dort irgendwo verschluckt wird.
Das wird wahrscheinlich auch einfach als technisches Problem rausgefiltert und dann einfach ignoriert, weil es nicht verstanden wird.
Ja, bedauerlicherweise.
Da steckt wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal böser Wille dahinter, aber das sollte sich auf jeden Fall ändern. Es gab ja auch noch andere positive Beispiele, wenn ich das richtig sehe. Das GPS-Navigation-System TomTom Go ist ja auch eines der populären Fälle gewesen bei GPL Violations, weil das jetzt jeder kennt, weil das ja auch ein ganz schmuckes Produkt ist. Wie hat sich das da weiterentwickelt? Sie sind mittlerweile ganz aufgeschlossen.
Ja, das ist richtig. Da kann man wirklich mal sagen, das ist das Paradebeispiel, wie sich eine Firma, also eine Firma, der man echt abnimmt, oh, da haben wir was übersehen, tut uns leid und wir setzen jetzt alles dran, dass das irgendwie sauber läuft. Das ist wirklich so ein Paradebeispiel dafür. Das heißt, man hat also da nicht nur selbstverständlich irgendwie gesagt, nein, es kommt nicht mehr vor, wir unterschreiben, das passiert nicht mehr, wir verbürgen uns dafür, dass wir da keine Verletzungen mehr haben in Zukunft. Sondern man hat darüber hinaus auch aktiv sich beraten lassen. Es gab also Schulungen bei denen vor Ort, die jetzt in dem Fall auch ich gemacht habe, das ist natürlich letztendlich egal, wer das macht, der kompetent ist mit der GPL. Die Entwickler und auch die Rechtsabteilung und auch das technische Management wurden also geschult im Bezug auf GPL. Und man hat da auch sehr, sehr offen geredet. Die haben dann sogar noch geholfen. Es hat sich ja so ein bisschen diese Open-Torm-Community gebildet, leider nur sehr klein, aber immerhin. Wo also Leute auch zum Beispiel einen MP3-Player mit auf das Navigationssystem drauf installiert haben und so. Und da gibt es dann sogar, hat mit der GPL jetzt gar nichts zu tun, aber ist sehr positiv zu sehen, da gibt es auch aktive Unterstützung. Das heißt, man hat uns da auch Hardware-Rokumentation zur Verfügung gestellt für das Open-Torm-Projekt und die Steckerbelegungen, was jetzt in Bezug auf Seriali-Konsole und JTAG-Cores...
Das sind ja auch immer genau diese problematischen Bereiche. Das ist das ganze Re-Engineering, was nötig ist, um Software auf Hardware zu laufen zu lassen, wo man eigentlich auch mal gar nicht versteht, warum die Hardware-Hersteller da einfach nicht aufwachen. Weil es so eine einfache Möglichkeit ist, sich Software-Support gerade in so einem wichtigen Markt wie im Embedded-Bereich zu bekommen, indem man das einfach dokumentiert. Weil wer es rauskriegen will, kriegt es eh raus. Also diese ganze Security bei Obscurity funktioniert nur in wenigsten Fällen. Und wenn dann nur wieder mit so viel Aufwand, dass es sich wahrscheinlich gar nicht lohnt.
Also weil, wie du schon sagst, die Leute finden es so und so raus, aber halt erst mit enden Monaten oder Jahren Aufwand.
Und dann nützt es ihnen auch gar nichts mehr. Genau. Und würden sie sich dann halt einfach da offener hinbegeben. Gut, es gibt so Bereiche, da ist es schwierig. In Grafikkarten sind glaube ich das beste Beispiel, wo ja sozusagen der Treiber schon wiederum so viel Software beinhaltet, dass es eigentlich schon ein Teil des Produktvorteils ist und des Wettbewerbsvorteils, den sie haben. Insofern gibt es da auf jeden Fall schwierige Bereiche, aber für einfache Hardware ist es eigentlich zu empfehlen, da von vornherein offen zu dokumentieren.
Richtig, aber das ist wirklich so eine kulturelle Umstellung, die gerade in der Hardware-Branche noch überhaupt absolut gar nicht passiert ist. Also ich habe da auch beruflich sehr viel zu tun damit. Ich bin ja eben freiberuflicher Entwickler, auch was Treiber angeht und so in dem Umfeld. Und da gibt es wirklich Hersteller jetzt nicht komplexe Grafikkarten, sondern von so Popel-Hardware, wie Chipkartenleser oder wie, sagen wir mal, ein Chip für PCMCIA-Stackkarten oder für so Flashkarten und solche Sachen. Also wirklich, wo man sagt, das ist jetzt nicht irgendwie Rocket Science, was da passiert, sondern das ist irgendwie ganz serviale Hardware im Prinzip. Nichts, wo ich durch Geheimhaltung irgendeinen Wettbewerbsvorteil gewinnen würde. Und trotzdem ist man da so dermaßen zugenagelt bei vielen Firmen und dokumentiert nicht und so weiter. Und das ist so alles in allem, auch völlig unabhängig vom GPL-Thema, ist die Mangel der Dokumentation zu Hardware der Bremsfaktor Nummer eins für freie Software, überhaupt egal, bei welchen Getreppen.
Ja, eigentlich müsste es mit Hardware genauso sein wie mit Nahrungsmitteln. Man muss einfach draufstehen, was drin ist. Vielleicht nicht bis in die letzte Zusammensetzung.
So in etwa.
Vielleicht können wir das ja mal kurz auf so einen kleinen... Ich bin jetzt eine Firma. Was muss ich beachten? Also ich habe ein Produkt, ich habe eine Hardware, die ist speziell und dann an einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt stelle ich fest, würde mir jetzt aber Linux oder irgendeine andere GPL Software würde mir jetzt extrem dabei helfen und ich müsste das und das und das nicht neu entwickeln. Gibt vielleicht auch noch einen gewissen Anteil, vielleicht auch der Hauptanteil, den ich auch selber noch an Software bereitstelle, aber auf jeden Fall könnte mir GPL Software weiterhelfen. Was soll eine Firma dann tun?
Ja, also zunächst ist eben wichtig, dass für die, also die Software wird dem Anwender, dem Kunden ja dann als Object-Code, als ausführbares Programm übergeben, dass man eben hier bei der Auslieferung dann dieses Produkt, den Lizenz-Text immer mitliefert, das muss nicht auf Papier sein, wir wollen ja nicht irgendwie Bäume töten, aber dann kann man ja einfach noch ein Text-File irgendwie auf die CD legen, mit dem manual.de, mit dem Produkt vertrieben wird. Also einfach die Lizenz aufgeführt, das versteht, ja, hier auf dem Produkt sind diese und jene Bestandteile unterstehen der GPL. Der Anwender hat da rechtlich darüber hinausgehen, was er normalerweise so gewohnt ist. Man muss dann eben auch aufpassen, wenn die Firmen eigene Lizenzverträge haben oder so komische Warranty-Bedingungen und so weiter, dass man halt das abstimmt, dass hier keine Widersprüche drin sind, das ist so ein bisschen Papierarbeit für irgendeinen Halbjuristen oder so. Und ich muss eben auch dann den Quellcode entweder gleich mitliefern, wie es eine Variante ist, das heißt eben gleich mit ausliefern mit dem Produkt, oder die andere Variante ist eben ihn anzubieten, das heißt, dem Produkt wird dann beigelegt, ein Zettelchen, wo drauf steht, naja, wer jetzt den Quellcode haben will, der melde sich bei oder wende sich an, Postanschrift oder E-Mail oder Webadresse oder was auch immer, und dann muss man den dort eben beziehen können in den zugehörigen Quellcode. Das heißt also mal so die Minimalanforderung, die auch wirklich absolut, wenn man sie von vorne hat, in einem Produktentwicklungsbereich mit berücksichtigt, auch echt kein Aufwand ist für so eine Firma. Wo es dann ein bisschen interessanter wird, sage ich mal, ist, wenn ich nicht nur einfach gebildete Software nehme und die wiedervertreibe, sondern wenn ich da Veränderungen, Bearbeitungen vornehme, also dann im Bereich der sogenannten Derivative Work, das abgeleitete Werk bekomme. Das heißt, jetzt zum Beispiel von Linux, wenn ich da noch Änderungen vornehme, zum Beispiel jetzt bei den DSL-Routern oder WLAN-Routern, hat man es häufig gesehen, dass da im Firewalling-Bereich für neue Protokolle irgendwie Unterstützung geschrieben wurde oder spezielle Port Scan Detection oder was auch immer für komische Mechanismen, die Firmen halt entwickelt haben. Und wenn das dann eben auf dem existierenden Netzwerk called the root, dann muss ich diese Erweiterungen, die ich dazu schreibe, muss ich dann eben auch wieder unter der GPL lizenzieren. Das muss ich mir von vornherein klar sein. Wenn ich so was mache mit GPL lizenzierter Software, dann habe ich eben diese Bestimmungen. Und das ist sicherlich einer der Punkte, wo viele Firmen mit zu wenig Überlegung an die Sache herangehen.
Eine Frage, die sich bestimmt auch viele stellen, ist, wie es denn eigentlich aussieht mit der Kopplung der eigenen Software. Weil da ist ja GPL auch so ein bisschen schwer auszulegen. Zumindest braucht man da so eine gewisse Erfahrung, um das zu verstehen. Aber wenn ich jetzt selber Software schreibe und ab welcher Form der Kopplung muss ich meine eigene Software auch unter GPL stellen? Welchen Unterschied macht die LGPL an der Stelle? Wo ist da die Linie? Und wie kann man auch für ein kleines Unternehmen wirklich sicherstellen, dass das, was sie eben auch nicht veröffentlichen wollen, das ist ja auch nachvollziehbar, dass sie das auch nicht müssen?
Ja, da gibt es halt eine Reihe von Fällen, die ganz eindeutig sind. Und dann gibt es eine Reihe von Fällen, da wird es dann schwierig, da gibt es dann Grauzonen. Aber eindeutig ist eben, wenn ich existierende Software nehme, dort tatsächlich mit dem Text-Editorium-Quelcode Änderungen vornehme und das dann übersetze und ausliebere, dann ist das ganz klar ein abgeleitetes Werk, weil ich habe existierenden Software-Code verändert. Das ist nicht irgendwie eine Neuentwicklung von mir. Das ist also ein ganz eindeutiger Fall. Ein ganz anderer eindeutiger Fall ist, wenn ich zum Beispiel den Linux-Betriebssystemkörner nehme, unverändert, und ich lasse dann ein Anwendungsprogramm laufen, das ich vollständig selber entwickelt habe. Das ist auch völlig klar, das sind getrennte Programme, die laufen in getrennten Adressbereichen, haben überhaupt nichts miteinander zu tun, sind nicht miteinander verlinkt, es ist keinerlei Integration zwischen den beiden da. Wenn es jetzt in Richtung Bibliotheken und Linken geht, da wird es dann etwas haariger, sage ich mal. Das heißt also so, wenn ich eine GPL-lizenzierte Bibliothek verwende, aus einem Programm heraus. Ich entwickle eine neue Software, die habe ich vollständig selber geschrieben, aber ich rufe dort Funktionen auf aus einer Bibliothek, die GPL-lizensiert ist. Ein Beispiel dafür, was man häufig in der Praxis sieht, ist libsmb-clients. Das ist also die Samba Client Library, mit der kann ich aus meinem Programm heraus auf Windows-File Shares zugreifen. Und wenn die Bibliothek der GPL unterliegt, dann kann ich die tatsächlich nur verwenden aus meinem Programm, wenn ich mein Programm auch wieder GPL-lizensiere. Das ist dann der Unterschied. Unterlege diese Bibliothek der LGPL, der Lesser General Public License, und dann hätte ich diese Möglichkeit. Weitverbreitetes Beispiel ist die Standard-C Bibliothek, die man unter Linux-Systemen findet. Das ist die glibc, die GNU-C Library. Und die ist eben der LGPL unterstellt. Und wenn ich jetzt ein Programm schreibe, ein Hello World Programm oder so, dann rufe ich da Funktionen auf, wie z.B. Printf. Also ich gebe etwas aus, einfach einen Text. Und dann verwende ich diese C Library, aber ist diese LGPL lizenziert, also kann ich mein Hello World Programm oder natürlich auch sehr viel komplexere Programme eben auch in der Wirkulite der Lizenzen stellen. Das sind also auch Fälle, die sehr eindeutig noch sind. Schwieriger wird es bei so Themen wie z.B. Binary-only-Kernel-Modulen, d.h. wenn ich Treiber-Module oder andere Bestandteile im Linux-Kernel eben nicht frei lizenziert haben will, das ist wirklich was, da ist eine Grauzone. Wenn ich auf der sicheren Seite bleiben will, würde ich einfach jeder Firma raten, lasst die Finger davon, macht es nicht, weigert euch, macht das sauber, dann habt ihr schon kein Risiko. Jeder, der sich in diese Grauzone hineinbegeht, begeht recht dieses Risiko ein. Viele Firmen machen das und ich denke, das wird nicht mehr unendlich lang gehen. Und irgendwann haben wir dann mal den ersten Fall auch vor Gericht und dann wird das mal ausgefucht. Und wie gesagt, wer sauber bleiben will, der bleibt halt bei diesen eindeutigen Fällen und lässt sich nicht auf so einen Mischmasch ein.
Schwierig wird es dann sicherlich auch nochmal bei solchen Sachen wie Web-APs und lokalen, losen Bindungen. Aber was mir jetzt gerade noch zu den Treibern an... Also Treiber sind ja schon seit längerer Zeit so ein hartes Thema. Das hat man ja jetzt eben auch schon den einen Aspekt. Ich glaube, letzte Woche hat Novell beschlossen aus dem SUSE Linux alle kommerziellen Treiber aus ihrer Distribution...
Nicht kommerziell.
Richtig, alle proprietären, also nicht im Source Code verfügbaren Treiber rauszuschmeißen. Weißt du, was da so die Motivation war dahinter? Ist das so Druck der Straße oder verfolgen die da jetzt auch wirklich einen...
Also wo die Motivation... Das ist jetzt sehr überrascht, muss ich sagen, weil Susi mit wohl schon, wenn ich mal so sagen darf, die Distribution, oder Susi Linux die Distribution immer war, die mit am freundlichsten noch sozusagen, jetzt nicht unbedingt am freundlichsten gegenüber den Entwicklungsunternehmen von proprietären Treibern, aber am freundlichsten dem Anwender gegenüber, der proprietäre Treiber einsetzen möchte. Und dass sie jetzt so auf einmal diese Policy rausgeben, also ich find's toll, IBM hat im Übrigen eine ähnliche Policy, hab ich noch nie offiziell irgendwo gehört, hab ich aber von Senior, also entsprechend autorisierten Leuten aus IBM schon mehrfach genannt bekommen, dass IBM eben auch keine Systeme ausliefert an Kunden, die mit proprietären Treibern arbeiten, machen die einfach nicht.
Ja, vielleicht wollen die auch einfach ihre Abhängigkeit da sicherstellen und das ist natürlich so ein Ding, weil gerade so Aging-Hardware ist immer so ein Thema, was passiert, wenn die Firma stirbt und der Code geht einfach mit weg und dann gibt es niemanden, der das kann, dann muss man selber Reverse-Engineering betreiben oder man muss das Ganze sein. Das sind eine ganze Menge Sicherheitsrisiken. Insofern ist das glaube ich auch für viele Firmen, also das ist gar nicht mal das einzige Argument, dass man die Software nicht selber schreiben muss, sondern dass man eben auch einfach auf ein ganz anderes Modell sitzt und damit auch sich in eine ganz andere Welt der Kooperation begibt, die am letzten Endes Abhängigkeiten erspart, die einfach nicht schön sind. Weil klar kann man Produkt XY einkaufen, dann zahlt man halt so und so viel Pfennig pro vertriebenes Produkt, aber dann ist halt diese Firma von heute auf morgen mal weg. Das Haus ist abgebrannt oder keine Ahnung, oder die Proamierer zahlen es der Firma halt.
Ist sie dann aufgekauft von irgendjemand, der nicht so gut gewillt ist mir gegenüber?
Der den gleich Markt bearbeitet.
Oder sie gehen insolvent, dann muss der Insolvenzverwalter die Rechte verkaufen an den Meistbietenden. Also es gibt da sehr viele Sachen, die als Damoples-Schwert immer ein bisschen drüberhängen. Man kann sich damit viel ersparen, das ist richtig. Gerade diese Abhängigkeit, diese Vendor-Login-Situation ist ganz wichtig und auch bei anderen Themen wie freien Dokumentenformaten und Ähnlichem auch eine ganz wichtige Thematik.
Okay, ich denke, wir haben das Thema jetzt auch weitgehend bearbeitet. Was ich allerdings noch mal ansprechen möchte, ist die dritte Version der GPL. Vor ein paar Wochen gab es eine Konferenz dazu in den USA. Da haben sich ein paar kluge Leute zusammengesetzt und darüber nachgedacht, wie das mit einer dritten Version wäre. Es gibt da auch schon erste Vorschläge. Was kannst du uns dazu sagen? Was soll diese dritte Version der GPL bereinigen? Was kommt dazu? Was ist da die Motivation?
Grundsätzlich ist es so, wenn wir die ganze Zeit von GPL reden, in unserem Radio oder auch sonst reden wir immer implizit von der GPL Version 2, das ist von 1991. Vorher gab es eine Version 1 von 1984 oder 1985. Es ist also schon so, dass es quasi eine Historie gibt, dass man diese Lizenzen updatet, wie man Software updatet, werden die Lizenzen geupdatet. Man muss einfach Entwicklungen einmal in der Technologie natürlich mit berücksichtigen. Was weiß ich, wie du schon meintest, auch WebARPs oder Application Service Provider, solche Dinge, Digital Restrictions Management, Systeme, DLM. Es gibt halt einfach viel technischen Fortschritt, der einfach noch nicht berücksichtigt wurde, weil die Lizenz zu einer Zeit geschrieben wurde, als das alles noch nicht existiert hat. Auch Embedded-Systeme in dem Sinne, mit freier Software hatte man einfach nicht im Sinn, als man die GPLv1 und v2 geschrieben hat. Bei v3 kann man das jetzt eben mit berücksichtigen. Also es ist ein natürlicher Fortentwicklungsprozess in der Reaktion auf die Umwelt, einmal die rechtliche Umwelt, einmal die technische Umwelt. Und bei der Konferenz, das war jetzt, wie soll man sagen, wo der erste Draft, die erste Vorschlagsversion veröffentlicht wurde auf dieser Konferenz in Boston, also dass jetzt der Start eines Prozesses im Laufe dessen die GPLv3 dann entwickelt werden soll, mit sehr viel Feedback auch von der Community und von den interessierten Parteien. Ich war da auch eingeladen, aber ich habe immer mit den USA so meine Probleme. So Fingerabdrücke abgeben bei der Einreise und so.
Macht keinen Spaß.
Nee, nicht wirklich. Wenn man sich den ersten Draft anschaut, was sich da getan hat, dann gibt es nicht viele Änderungen, aber es gibt ein paar, die herausragen. Nummer eins ist Digital Restriction Management, Digital Rights Management, DRM, wo klargestellt wird, was eigentlich die GPLv2 auch schon implizit will, dass man die Freiheit der freien Software nicht durch DRM-Mechanismen einschränken darf. Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt ein Gerät entwickle, geben wir da Position Evil Corp, ich mache ein Evil Device, und da kommt Linux zum Einsatz und ich baue da einen Bootloader oder sogar einen Prozessor oder wo auch immerhin einen Mechanismus ein, der durch das Beprüfen von cryptografischen Prüfsummen oder was auch immer verhindert, dass jemand veränderte Linux Kernel-Versionen dort zur Ausführung dringt auf dem Gerät, der befindet sich nicht mit der GPL im Eingang. Das ist eigentlich bei der Version 2, so zumindest meine und auch die Interpretationen von vielen anderen, ist das auch implizit klar, weil es steht halt nicht so drin. Hingegen in der Version 3 wird explizit auf so einen Fall eingegangen, also jetzt in dem ersten Vorschlag davon, und es wird reingeschrieben, dass wenn man so etwas macht, dann muss man eben entweder die Schlüssel mitgeben zum Signieren oder man muss sonst irgendwie eine Möglichkeit schaffen, also zum Beispiel dadurch, dass man einen neuen Schlüssel in die Hardware einspielen kann, dass die dann eben nur noch von mir signierte Objekte annimmt.
Bezieht sich das auch auf diese Trusting Computing Geschichte?
Nicht so direkt. Also, Trusting Computing ist halt so die, wie soll ich sagen, die komplexeste, ausgefeilteste DIM-Variante, wie wir sie bisher gesehen haben, würde ich mal sagen. Da bezieht sich sicher mit drauf. Aber man sieht es eben jetzt schon bei sehr viel Embedded-Geräten auch, dass solche Sachen gemacht werden. Das ist also wirklich ein Problem, dass es nicht wirklich eindeutig in der aktuellen Version 2 drinsteht. Deswegen geht man hier in die Version 3 her und sagt, wir schreiben das jetzt ganz deutlich rein, was wir eigentlich schon immer wollten, um hier keine Missverständnis entstehen zu lassen. Diese DIM-Thematik ist eine andere Thematik. Da geht es um Softwarepatente. Softwarepatente sind sowieso eine Bedrohung für Software im Allgemeinen, für freie Software eben auch. Man reagiert hier auch ein bisschen auf rechtlich kulturelle Dinge. In US-amerikanischen Lizenzverträgen sieht man häufig sogenannte Patent Retaliation-Sachen. Das heißt, ich lizenziere ein Patent dem Gegenüber nur so lange, bis das Gegenüber gegen mich Patentklage erhebt wegen irgendeinem anderen Patent. Das heißt, ich überlasse ihnen die Rechte an dem Patent und die Nutzung der Dinge, die da patentiert sind, kostenlos. Sie können machen, was sie wollen, aber wenn die anfangen, mir ins Bein zu pinkeln, dann nehme ich auf.
Mausche Wirtschaft sozusagen.
Und die GPLv3 in dem Draft hat explizit was drin, dass sie ergänzt werden darf. Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt irgendwie Technologie habe, die Software-Patenten unterliegt in einer Software, dann muss ich die ja lizenzieren gegenüber den Abnehmern, sonst wäre es nicht mit der GPL im Einklang. Das heißt, die Software muss frei sein. Das heißt, wenn ich ein Software-Patent auf Software habe und ich lasse es als GPL-lizenzierte Software vertreiben, muss ich auch dem Abnehmer das Recht geben an diesem Software-Patent. Also dass er eben die Software nutzen kann. Aber ich darf eben zusätzlich, wenn ich das möchte, jetzt mit dieser Version 3-Draft, kann ich eben noch hinzuschreiben, dass wenn der anfängt, mir wegen Patenten ans Bein zu pinkeln, dann darf ich das auch wieder rufen. Solche Dinge, wo man so ein bisschen auf juristische Dinge reagiert hat. Ein anderer sehr wichtiger Punkt meiner Meinung nach ist die Lizenz-Kompatibilität. Als die GPL 1 und 2 geschrieben wurde, gab es kaum andere Copy-Left-Freie-Software-Lizenzen. Die BSD-Lizenz gibt es, aber das ist keine Copy-Left-Lizenz. Mittlerweile gibt es aber sehr viele Lizenzen. Die Sun-CDDL, Sun-Community-License, Apple hat ja auch zwei verschiedene APSL-Lizenzen usw. Alle möglichen Lizenzen werden erfunden. Die GPLv3 hat also mehr Vorkehrungen juristischer Natur, um es leichter zu machen, Kompatibilität zwischen so unterschiedlichen Lizenzen zu ermöglichen. Das macht die ganze Formulierung leider deutlich komplexer. Also wenn man den Text sich liest, ist es deutlich schwerer verständlicher als die GPLv2. Das kann man hoffentlich noch etwas ausbügeln.
Das klingt ja jetzt alles so, dass wenn, sagen wir mal, morgen würde irgendwie alles, was heute unter GPLv2 verfügbar ist, auf einmal unter GPLv3 stehen, hätte das ja schon doch bedeutende Auswirkungen auf die Entwicklung der Märkte mit Digital Rides Management zum Beispiel oder Restriction Management, um es richtig zu fassen. Allerdings gab es, schätze ich das falsch ein?
Ja, naja, nein. Es ist halt so, wenn man über DRM spricht, dann spricht man meistens über DRM von Content, also um Medien. Da geht es ja bei der GPL nicht darum, sondern bei der GPL geht es um DRM auf Software-Bezug. Es ist ja nicht so, dass ich nach wie vor mit der GPLv3 DRM Software zum Beispiel schreibe, die dann Restriction Management auf Content macht. Das kann man jetzt für ethisch verwerflich halten, aber bei der GPL geht es eben um die Softwarelizenz. Solange die Software selbst nicht auch Teil des DRM-Systems ist, habe ich da weniger Probleme.
Aber es geht auch um die Einschränkung von Hardware-Plattformen. Zum Beispiel Xbox ist ein Thema, wo man Microsoft aktiv versucht hat, zu verhindern, dass dort überhaupt ein Linux zum Laufen kommt. Und es droht natürlich auch auf PC-Ebene im Allgemeinen, dass solche Systeme sich breit machen, damit eben große Firmen da ihre Märkte sichern können. Aber gut, ist aber heute nicht so. Bestehende Software muss ja sozusagen neu unter dieser Lizenz veröffentlicht werden. Zunächst einmal, wann ist damit zu rechnen, dass diese GPLv3 fertig ist?
Na ja, also ich würde mal sagen, in einem knappen Jahr oder so vielleicht. Also es gibt so ein anvisiertes Datum, glaube ich, im Herbst des Jahres. Aber so genau weiß man das natürlich nie, wo so viele Leute mitreden und kommentieren und diskutieren. Aber ich denke mal, ein Jahr ist auf jeden Fall ein vertriebbarer Zeitraum.
Aber es gab ja schon einigen, Widerstand will ich jetzt noch nicht sagen, aber zumindest Diskussionen darum. Linus Torvalds hat sich da zu Wort gemeldet. Ich weiß nicht so richtig, was davon zu halten ist.
Ja, vielleicht müssen wir mal kurz ein bisschen ausholen und sagen, es ist ja so, dass wenn ich jetzt Software schreibe und eine GPL-Lizenz erstelle, dann habe ich eben die Möglichkeit, so einen Standard-Disclaimer reinzumachen in die Software, oben in den Quelltext, den die Free Software Foundation empfiehlt. Und da steht eben drin, GPL Version 2 or at your option at any later Version. Das heißt also, wenn ich als Software-Autor in meine Software das so reingeschrieben habe, dann darf jeder sowieso GPL 2 oder jede nachfolgende Version verwenden. Das ist also bei vieler Software der Fall, also eigentlich bei aller Software, die von der Free Software Foundation selbst kommt, also zum Beispiel die GLEP 10, na gut, die selben GPL, schlechtes Beispiel, ok. Was weiß ich, GNU VCD-Imager oder was auch immer es für Programme gibt, das sind GNU Project, Bash, den GCC, den Compiler, was auch immer alles. Die haben eben entsprechend so drin stehen, das heißt die werden dann auch ab dem Tag der Verfügbarkeit der Version 3 auch unter dieser Lizenz stehen zusätzlich. Was aber jetzt Software betrifft, insbesondere der Linux Kernel, da ist es eben so, dass man dieses Or Any Later Version rausgestrichen hat, das mache ich bei meiner Software auch immer so, ganz einfach, weil ich das irgendwie sehr suspekt finde, wenn ich als Autor jetzt sage, naja, ich lizenziere die nach einer Lizenz, wo ich noch gar nicht weiß, wie die vielleicht aussehen mag. Das finde ich ein bisschen komisch. Also ich vertraue der Free Software Foundation und so, das ist ja alles gar kein Thema, aber trotzdem, egal wie gut ich jemandem vertraue, ich vertraue eigentlich niemanden jetzt so blind, dass ich sage, naja, egal was der sich für Dinge ausdenken mag, ich stimme schon mal in Vornherein zu, was er sagt. Also das finde ich immer ein bisschen kritisch. Und deswegen sage ich auch, also meine Software ist alles GPL Version 2 explizit dezensiert und wenn es jetzt eine Version 3 gäbe, dann muss ich mir als Entwickler eben Gedanken machen, möchte ich jetzt die auch unter die Version 3 stellen oder nur in Zukunft neue Versionen davon oder wie auch immer. Und das ist natürlich bei einem Projekt der Größe des Linux-Körnels, wo so viele tausend Leute irgendwie teilen, ein Stückchen vom Urheberrechten teilt man relativ schwierig.
Was wird sich denn noch kurz oder lang sowieso mischen? Also man hat ja dann irgendwann einen Körnel, der voll ist mit Version 2 und mit Version 3 und die eine Zahl ist 3 und die andere Zahl ist 2.
Na ja, 2 only und 3 only wird es nicht geben können. Das ist wahrscheinlich nicht... Kann ich jetzt nicht im Detail, aber ich würde vermuten, dass es nicht gerechtlich ist. Das heißt, was es schon geben kann, ist, dass jemand sagt, na ja, 2 und 3. Und dann gibt es andere Sachen, die halt sagen, na ja, wir sind nur 2. Das werden wir sehr sensationell sehen. Das denke ich auch, dass mit dem Tag, wo die Version 3 erschienen ist, wird es bestimmt den einen oder anderen Körneleitwickler geben, der sagt, ja, alles, was ich mache, das ist jetzt auch in der Version 3. Aber dass jemand sagt, nur 3 und später, das ist dann wahrscheinlich nicht kompatibel mit der Version 2.
Was hat dir jetzt Linus Torweiss konkret auszusetzen?
Ich weiß nicht. Linus reagiert auch manchmal aus dem Bauch heraus bei solchen Sachen. Da gibt es jetzt die Version 3 und es wird ja seit Jahren darüber gesprochen, dass es vielleicht mal eine Version 3 der GPL gäbe. Und es gab da schon immer so ein bisschen, wie soll ich sagen, also Stormen auf der anderen Seite, Linus Torweiss auf der einen Seite, so eine gewisse Spannung, sage ich mal, was auf GPL Version 3. Niemand wusste, was ihr eigentlich zu Ihnen haben habt, aber man war schon von vornherein irgendwie, war man sich sicher, dass man unterschiedlicher Meinung sein wird. Und von daher würde ich das jetzt auch noch nicht so als das letzte Wort nehmen in der ganzen Debatte. Ich hatte auch das Gefühl, was Linus da geschrieben hatte, man hat so den Eindruck gemacht, als ob er es noch nicht hundertprozentig verstanden hätte, was die GPL-Version 3 in dem Draft jetzt eigentlich will. Das war, denke ich, jetzt erstmal so eine aus dem Bauch Reaktion, da werden wir sicher noch abwarten müssen. Es ist der Free Software Foundation auch sehr stark daran gelegen, dass sozusagen hier die Interessen der Kernentwicklungs-Community berücksichtigt werden und dass man sozusagen auch jetzt...
Zu einem einmütigen Ergebnis kommt.
Genau, dass man keine V3 macht, in der dann, wie soll ich sagen, das größte und bekannteste Projekt sozusagen irgendwie nicht drunter zur Verfügung steht.
Gut, zu einem einmütigen Ergebnis sollten wir jetzt auch kommen. Jetzt haben wir hier eine Stunde geredet über Lizenzen. Schön trockenes Thema, aber ich hoffe, es hat trotzdem Spaß gemacht und neue Informationen für euch gebracht.
Genau, Chaosradio mit Bildungsanspruch.
Genau, Chaosradio mit Bildungsanspruch. Das geht natürlich auch immer so weiter, wenn ihr Feedback habt zu diesem Thema, was wir jetzt besprochen haben. Wenn ihr dann noch Details kennt, interessante Sachen, dann teilt uns das doch einfach mit. Und zwar entweder per E-Mail, chaosradio.ccc.de, oder wie ihr auch in dieser Sendung schon gehört, nutzt das Telefon unter 018 01 99 33 22 99 55. Gibt es einen Anrufbeantworter, dann könnt ihr einfach drauf plappern und dann seid ihr hier mit dabei. Die Nummer findet sich auch auf der Webseite unter chaosradio.ccc.de. Die Musik sollten wir hier noch erwähnen. Das ist wieder mal ein Mix von Baldo mit dem Titel Southern Sounds. Den Link findet ihr dann auch auf der Webseite zu dieser Sendung. Das ist selbstverständlich wieder Creative Commons Musik, die ich ausschließlich verwende. Es gibt ja im Podcast-Universum da auch noch ein paar andere Trends mit zum Beispiel das PodSafe Music Network. Da ist mir noch nicht so ganz klar, was die langfristigen Konsequenzen sind von Musik, die explizit nur für Podcasts freigegeben wird. Weil was macht man, wenn das dann wieder weiterverwendet wird und woanders hin getragen wird? Das ist schwierig, aber das CC-Archiv, das ist groß genug. Da braucht man auf nichts zu verzichten. Das wächst auch täglich an. Interessante neue Sachen gibt es auch unter ccmixter.com. Aber ich wollte nicht so viel über Musik reden, sondern ich wollte noch die nächste Chaosradio-Sendung ankündigen, die sich eigentlich mit dem Netlabel-Thema beschäftigen sollte. Das Thema haben wir noch ein bisschen verschoben. Wahrscheinlich hier ins Chaosradio Express verschoben. Stattdessen wird es eine interessante Diskussion geben zu einem Thema, was den letzten Kongress auch ein bisschen umgepflugt hat. Dieser We Lost the War-Diskussion. Inwieweit die Hacker-Szene oder vielleicht auch wir alle verloren haben den Krieg gegen die Leute, die die Freiheit einschränken wollen. Es gibt ja auch täglich wieder neue Beispiele, wohin das Ganze führt. Ich sage nur Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft, was da wieder alles auf uns...
Im Bundestag gibt es jetzt die Debatte in Richtung Vorratsdatenspeicherung, Umsetzung der UU-Richtlinien und so.
Ja, es nimmt alles kein Ende. Um das noch mal zu reviewn und da auch mal ein bisschen Meinungsbildung, Meinungsreflektion zu betreiben, gibt es dort eine interessante Runde Chaosradio. 110 am 22. Februar um 22 Uhr auf Radio Fritz live auch im Internet zu empfangen über verschiedene Art und Weisen. Die Links zu den Streams findet ihr wie immer auf unserer Radio-Seite. Ihr könnt auch gerne im Chat teilnehmen. Da gibt es den AC-Kanal dazu. Das steht alles auch auf unserer Webseite. Wir freuen uns auf jeden Fall immer über Beteiligung. Dann sind wir jetzt hier eigentlich mit dem Thema so weit durch. Wir wollten noch auf zwei, drei Veranstaltungen hinweisen, die jetzt hier in den nächsten Wochen im nahe deutschen Raum interessant werden. Am 25. oder 26. Februar gibt es die Vorstamm. Das ist eigentlich so das größte Treffen von Open-Source-Entwicklern. Dort sind alle Open-Source-Entwickler. Das haben wir im vorletzten Chaosradio Express auch schon erwähnt. Das ist jetzt halt 25. oder 26. Februar. Richtig, genau, in Brüssel auf dem Universitätsgelände. Am 4. oder 5. März gibt es in Chemnitz die Chemnitzer Linux Tage. Das findet man unter chemnitzer.linuxtage.de. Dann am Anfang April gibt es eine Veranstaltung, wo du, glaube ich, auch gebucht bist, Harald, wo ich das richtig sehe. Die OSKON Vienna hat nichts mit der OReille OSKON zu tun.
Das ist eine österreichische Konferenz, wo es im Wesentlichen um die Schnittstelle zwischen Community und kommerziellen Anwendern geht. Das heißt, eben auch um Lizenzthema. GPL Version 3 wird sicherlich auch angesprochen werden. Aber eben auch um binary-only-Driver und Hardware ohne Dokumentation und so diese ganzen Problembereiche zwischen Kommerz und Community.
Ja, dann kurz darauf, vier Tage später ist dann auch der Easter-Hack über Ostern auch in Wien. Da kann man also glatt eine ganze Woche in dem Themenbereich dort in Wien abhängen. Und das letzte, was uns noch aufgefallen ist, in Karlsruhe dann Ende April gibt es eine Linux-Audio-Konferenz von den Linux-Audio-Entwicklern für die Leute, die das interessiert. Ja, das war's. Wir verabschieden uns. Es ist mal wieder richtig schön lange geworden, die Sendung. Oh Gott, 76 Minuten. Wir entschuldigen uns. Aber es ist immerhin nicht drei Stunden wie beim Chaosradio.
Hey, wir können es ja einfach schneller abspielen.
Genau.
Okay, super. Dann verabschieden wir uns. Bis zum nächsten Mal.